When you're creating gadgets of any kind, you want to know the individual pieces.
You can't solve the puzzle without knowing what your puzzle pieces are.
And I think it's really important to understand what the different components are, because
then you're hacking when you're away from your computer.
Then you can go for a critical, critical, critical thinking.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical think, right?
Hey, what's up critical thinking family?
Today we have a dear friend of mine.
His name is Kieran.
Most of you probably already know of him, but his hacker handle is monkey.
And we'll get into a little bit more of his story later, but for now, you know, the ritual
we have to jump straight into a bug.
So what did you bring us today, Kieran?
Well, I have three bugs.
What?
Because, yeah.
Are you trying to one up all our previous guests?
Yeah, we'll jump into the bugs, I guess.
I do a lot of client side stuff.
So hopefully that translates well on the audio format because you know how client side can
be.
Well, our listeners have heard Justin describe enough of running bugs.
I'm trying to get confused.
I'll ask questions.
I'll play the listener here.
Yeah.
Um, so first bug was account takeover via post message on a public program that I can't name
for obvious reasons.
Um, what made it really interesting was like the sheer number of, um, gadgets we had to
bring in.
I was doing this with my friend, Animesh, who's a, he's Australian researcher.
Cool.
So, uh, we, we spent like, I think like a week or something on this, but basically the idea
was, yeah, we, we got high bounty from it.
So that was, that was awesome.
Nice.
Um, but there was several pieces to this bug.
Um, the core of it was that there was, uh, an XSS in a chat widget that was on the page
and that had a gadget that let you leak the, uh, the HREF of the parent.
So this, this chat widget was in an iframe and the exploit we had was to leak the OAuth
code from the, the parent URL.
Uh, it had this like logging thing that would like send the, the, that read the parent HREF.
And so, um, I need to like, remember which, so basically the, this chat widget,
the, the, the, the, the URL you give it in like an iframe source.
Mm-hmm.
So you could send it a JavaScript protocol and it would pop XSS in the context of the
chat widget.
Um, and this, this, they had like four or five iframes on this page.
Like the victim.com had like four or five iframes.
And so, uh, the problem was that they had an origin check.
Um, but you know, that allows custom JavaScript for their custom domains.
Oh yeah.
Of course.
So I could get a window reference by hosting custom JavaScript on, was it, is origin and
do a window.open to the victim page.
And then you could send a post message and bypass the origin check.
Cause it's like it, it was a from a origin.
So it would.
Yeah.
And so that was great, except the OAuth flow had coop.
It had cross origin opener policy.
And I think Justin's discussed this recently, but it was a huge pain for, for post message
bugs.
Um, but Animish then discovered that you could fixate the state and what that would let you
do would, it would like jump you one step ahead in the OAuth flow.
Um, so it wasn't, it wasn't like slash authorize or whatever.
It was like the next step over, which didn't have coop.
So we would like generate the OAuth state on our end, fixate it in the victim.
And it wasn't tied to the victim session or anything or any of that.
So we could generate a state and have it be valid.
And that would then redirect to, um, the page with the, the iframes and stuff.
And with these kinds of bugs, you need like a dirty dancing, uh, gadget of some kind because
you need the code to be unused and to sit in the URL.
Right.
So what I did here, I double URL encoded a hash fragment.
So on the first redirect, it would decode once on the second redirect to our victim page,
it would decode twice, but it would put the code parameter in the hash fragment when it
did that.
So it wouldn't be processed, but you could still snag it.
Exactly.
So the full chain was like window.open to this fixated state, which would redirect with the
double URL encoded hash fragment and put the code in the URL.
Then I'd send a post message to one of the chat widget frames, but that wasn't the one
that had the logging mechanism.
So I would like, I frame hop over from the first frame to the second frame, cause they're
the same origin.
And when they're the same origin, you can, uh, change the JavaScript and then you can
overwrite the DOM.
Yeah.
So I would like hijack the frame with the logging thing.
I would trigger the log.
So the parent href would leak to the, the Salesforce chat.
And then I would, uh, exfiltrate from there.
Cause that's just exercise in the chat.
And they fixed that.
Otherwise, I wouldn't talk about it.
But yeah, did you have a, um, did you have like the whole thing automated and set up or
did you just like record it once for the demo and submit it or, or do you have it like
replayable so they could, so they could redo it?
Yeah.
I had a, so the, I, this took so long to get through triage.
I ended up writing this code snippet that would generate the state on my server.
Yeah.
And then the JavaScript on would get the fresh state from my server each time.
Generate the POC.
It was, it was a really big POC.
Yeah.
That's cool though.
That's amazing.
All right.
Bug number two.
Bug number two was I got account to take over without being logged in client side.
Um, which seems impossible, but so there was a unauthenticated, uh, CSTI.
So client side template injection, it was in angular.
Um, but the problem was it only existed in the context where you weren't logged in.
Um, yeah.
So yeah, this sounds very interesting.
So did it, is it like, uh, did it execute and then wait?
And then when they did log in, is it like X full to you?
Tell us how this works.
So the key here was that they had a mirror domain.
That was not the same, uh, domain as, as the one we X assessed.
Yeah.
That had the same cookies.
But of course, same origin policy applies.
So you can't just reach over and, and read.
Right.
That's just not how it works.
So what they did have was they had this, if this is another post message thing where they
had a post message listener that would, uh, send the, the user's credentials to the parent,
but they had frame ancestors.
And what that means is unless it was in one of the, uh, pages owned by the company, they
wouldn't let you do that post message, uh, sending the cookies to the parent.
Mm-hmm.
Um, and the other problem was that if you received the cookies in an unauthenticated scenario,
like in the CST page, it would like log in and redirect.
So that, that would break the whole chain as well because you know, you can't do anything.
So what I ended up doing here with the XSS, I, I framed the, the same page with the CST.
I select example.com.
I framed example.com.
Okay.
And then I purged the DOM because they're the same origins.
So you can just wipe the DOM.
Mm-hmm.
And in that I put an iframe with the other, uh, page that had logged in, but that was a
different domain.
Okay.
And that would meet the criteria for the frame ancestors.
But because I purged the DOM, the JavaScript that would redirect no longer existed.
Right.
So then I could trigger the chain where I send the post message, get the creds, which would
go to my purged one.
And that would exfil to, to my origin.
So you had, you had a template injection based XSS.
CSTi, the top.
On.
Yeah.
Then I had an iframe.
Right.
Yeah.
But then I had the other origin at the very bottom.
Right.
The one where they're actually logged into.
Yeah.
And I purged the middle one so it wouldn't redirect, but it would keep the frame ancestors.
But because of the frame ancestors, you could kind of like reach into the, to the one they
were logged into to grab the creds and then exfiltrate them.
Yeah.
The frame ancestors white listed the, the CSTi page.
But by, by putting, by purging the DOM, I don't trigger the, the code that would cause
the redirect and break everything.
So I, so I guess this would always work, right?
Yeah.
When, anytime you want to kind of reach across with a post message from, um, one domain,
when you can't, you could potentially use that same XSS to do what you did in most of
those cases.
Right.
You could wipe the DOM, make it iframe.
If you have a scenario where the DOM has code that breaks something, you can iframe itself
because you know, even with, um, most frame restrictions, it's even if it's same origin,
you can still iframe yourself and you can just purge the DOM and like, keep, keep the
benefits of the same origin, but not the problems with any code on it.
Right.
Any code that's like kind of a blank slate, like a playground almost.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
All right.
And the third one is a server side bug, right?
Yes.
Because as much as I like client side, I don't want to just be a client side guy.
So we should have, we should have alternated it.
We should have put the server side in the middle to kind of balance it out there.
Probably.
For any listeners that aren't gone yet, tell us about the server side bug.
Yeah.
So this was during my like a hundred hour challenge I did for the newsletter last year.
That did really well.
Yeah, it went quite well.
I was pretty happy with it.
Um, and so basically there was a proxy, like proxy API and it had the classic URL parameter.
Um, I did actually pop SSRF on this URL parameter, but that's not what this bug is.
This is a different bug in the same place.
Uh, so I was just playing around with it as you always do when you find something strange.
Mm-hmm.
And then I did a relative path because that's always worth checking, not just HTTPS, but just a slash.
Sure.
And it gave me this error that was like jar protocol, not allowed.
And I was like, this is really weird.
Like what, what is this?
And you weren't passing a jar file to it or anything.
No, it was just a slash.
It was a URL equals slash.
So I was like, this is super strange.
Um, and then I did like slash X and it gave me class path resource does not exist.
Mm-hmm.
Now when you hear class path immediately, it's like Java.
Yep.
Because Java is the most common for classes.
Um, and so I asked PM and H who is like a God at Java stuff.
He's written a book on spring security.
So yeah, he's like my go-to friend for, for the server side stuff.
And he was like, Oh, maybe it's this.
Um, and basically, uh, if I put the class path protocol, which is apparently a protocol
in spring, it didn't error, which meant what it was doing was it was loading whatever file
I gave it inside the certain function in spring that was made for loading chairs.
Interesting.
Um, so were you able to write a jar file into that?
No.
Okay.
This was unfortunately a low bug.
It was just really, really cool.
Okay.
So he was like, try like slash meta inf, which is like, right.
Pretty much a default file in all jars.
And that gave me the same error, jar protocol, not allowed.
So by playing around with that, I figured out what it was doing was if the file name existed,
it would give me jar protocol, not allowed.
And if it didn't exist, it would say class path resource not found.
Mm-hmm.
So then I could just use this to fuzz the entire, like the file names of all the source code
they had, all of their jars.
That's funny.
So it was basically like a file name disclosure.
Yeah, but I couldn't load them and I couldn't like get RC or anything.
Cause I couldn't actually, it was just for loading up the jars and not executing them.
Once you knew what those files were that existed, did you try to browse any of them?
I guess you could have done the same thing if the, if you didn't have that gadget where
you just tried to browse to them, but because they were server side, it wouldn't load anyways.
But yeah.
Yeah.
But I could like, I use the program name and like fuzzed all the, like the file names and
stuff.
So I got quite a lot of information for just differentiating between two error messages.
Yeah, that's cool.
You know?
So yeah, it was a fun one.
Nice dude.
Well, to give people a little bit of different backstory, um, on kind of your history and
our history, um, Kieron, uh, and I met in a really cool way actually.
So I was working at app Omni and we were trying to hire another researcher for the labs team,
which you've probably heard me talk about before.
That's where I worked with, uh, Aaron Costello and, uh, I hop on a call and, uh, this guy's
face is sitting there and he's like, Hey, do you do bug bounty?
Are you an ambassador?
Are you an ambassador for hacker one?
I was like, yeah, I am.
And he's like, I am too.
And so Kieron is, uh, yeah.
Yeah.
That was like the second batch.
So there was only like 20 something ambassadors.
Yeah.
There was a pretty small crowd.
And then obviously the bug bounty space is pretty small.
So, uh, anytime you meet somebody in bug bounty, you know, it's like, uh, there's a kindred
spirit there.
Yeah.
You were like, Oh, I'm also an ambassador.
I'm also an ambassador for, for Kentucky.
And I was like, what?
Yeah.
Did you?
You didn't know that, right?
You didn't like pre look me up or anything.
No, I had no idea.
We just kind of happened to tease it out, which is cool.
So Kieron, then of course I lobbied hard to get him hired and ended up getting hired at
App Omni.
And how long did you work there with us?
For two years.
Yeah.
It was about two years.
I know you were kind of like full-time then part-time then, uh, do it like you were doing
schooling and everything else.
I was shuffling it with university as well.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Um, so kind of sweet.
We, we got to work together for, for a while.
Um, and that probably honestly what made us become even better friends.
And now we're both full-time bug bounty hunters.
So we're still colleagues.
Uh, we, we get to collab a lot and, uh, we're actually currently, we're currently hacking
on something this week with our buddy Archangel Douglas day.
Um, and I think you were going to mention that he had just launched a newsletter, right?
Yeah.
I think he's getting more into his, uh, his creative side.
Um, so he launched a newsletter called Eric angel drops.
So, yeah.
And if you just go to Douglas dot day, you can click like newsletter there on the left.
And you also, yeah, his domain is so cool.
I know I always mention that on the podcast, but, uh, if I, I wish I could get first name
dot last name, I don't think, uh, it's going to be a TLD for, uh, so you might not be able
to do that.
You could get hacker someday, you know?
Yeah.
I think me, Justin and I might've mentioned that on a recent, but yeah, if I could get
like Joseph T dot hacker, where it's my name with a dot after the first letter of my last
name, he'll be pretty sweet.
Yeah.
Um, yeah.
Tell us a little bit.
I mean, just if there's like anything, we don't need to get into your whole backstory,
but if you think there's like kind of any, anything interesting or inspiring to up and
coming bug hunters, I mean, you're pretty young and you've already been at a few live
hacking events and, um, you know, you seem to know everyone else in the industry.
Um, yeah, I guess just tell us a little bit about kind of that, how you got there.
And if anybody, you know, doesn't know you and you want something, want them to know
something about you.
Um, yeah, in case you can't tell from his accent, Kieran is from Ireland.
I can, I can run through how I got into bug bounty and stuff for sure.
Yeah.
So the main motivation was that I just had no money in college.
Um, and I was like, I need money.
I was pretty good at writing code in the past, um, like doing Python and stuff.
So, and then I found bug bounty.
I think it was through stocks videos.
Yeah.
What did you see?
Like maybe ran across on YouTube.
Yeah.
I was like doing the same stupid, like how to make money online crap that, you know,
a lot of us go through at some point.
And, and then I found stocks videos and he had like live hacking event, uh, vlogs, right?
Yeah.
Had you done any CTF stuff?
So do you think the algorithm knew you might be interested or at that point you had not?
I have no idea.
At some point I came across them and then I, I was watching his videos.
Like, this is so cool.
Like I really want to go to one of these things.
And so from there, I think I joined the bug crowd discord server and I met my friend, Mikey,
Mikey 96, who's been like friends since the very start of my security career.
Yeah.
Um, and, and so from there, I just kind of went through the same cycle of like reporting
crap bugs into reporting good bugs into reporting like fun chains now.
Yeah.
Um, and, but my first venture into security was very much bug bounty and not CTF.
Like I took the unusual path of bug bounty to CTF rather than the, the reverse.
Yeah.
So you did some cool stuff at your university, right?
Once you were kind of into bug bounty into hacking, you kind of, uh, kind of spearheaded
that there at your university, right?
Yeah.
So I exactly.
So I got into the hacker one ambassador program, um, pretty early on in, in my bug bounty journey.
And a bunch of us got invited to H1702 two years ago.
That was in, or yeah, more than two now that's 2022.
And while I was there, um, I went for a breakfast.
I think it was in Denny's in Vegas with a bunch of other hackers.
Classic.
And then Justin was there and he realized I could speak Japanese.
So he just pulled me aside and just.
Yeah.
And Justin is half Japanese.
Like his mother is Japanese.
So for, yeah, for context, I, I live in Edinburgh and Scotland, but I'm half Irish,
half Japanese.
I grew up in Ireland.
And so the minute Justin realized that I could speak Japanese, his like inner wanting to practice
his language skills came out.
And yeah, from there, I think he just had introduced me to like a lot more hackers and stuff.
So that was a huge, huge moment for me, honestly.
Yeah.
I did.
I plus one you to that 702.
I feel like I may have, but, uh, I don't know.
But I, but that was shortly after I started working at app on these.
So we were hanging out for a bit for sure.
Yeah.
Cool.
And then, um, yeah.
So, and then obviously I was at of late kind of a cool thing.
We're, we're going to both going to be at Google's Tokyo, um, live event coming up in
April, which should, which should be really cool again with Justin.
Um, yeah.
And so, uh, hopefully we'll find some great bugs.
I think it's AI focus.
So, um, I was going to mention that I know before I do want to like circle back to hearing
what you and link are cooking up, but, um, uh, I know that you also kind of have a penchant
for, for AI hacking.
You and I have looked at a bunch of different AI products.
Um, was there anything you wanted to say kind of in that regard that you thought was
cool or that you, uh, have been doing?
Oh, sorry.
And did I even mention that Kieron's a researcher at, at, uh, CTBB.
Yeah.
So Kieron, Kieron is one of the handful of people that, uh, Justin brought on to the CTBB research
team.
So it's, it's him, Matan Bear, um, Kevin, who we heard from last week, um, or I guess it'll
be two weeks ago by the time this goes out.
Um, no, I think it's Hako and Franz as well.
Yeah.
Uh, who is it?
It's Hako, Haku Piku and Franz.
Yeah.
Franz and Haku Piku.
So I guess, yeah, maybe cover a little bit of what you're doing with the research lab and
then the AI hacking stuff.
Yeah.
Sure.
Um, I think the research lab is very heavily client side focused at the moment.
Um, I mean, the other guys are geniuses.
They're finding some really cool stuff, but, um, I have one bit of research I want to talk
about today very briefly.
Um, because it's a piece of research that I just don't have the time to work on myself
now.
So I'm hoping someone will listen to this and like, look at this behavior I'm about to describe
and, you know, take it somewhere and do something with it.
Yeah.
This is a free bone for the listeners, right?
It is.
Um, and so, and it's server side, so this is a nice bit of variety.
Um, but to do with web sockets, uh, and so I was messing with web sockets recently enough
a few months ago, just because I think they're very underappreciated, not just from a bug bounty
standpoint, um, but from just a general research standpoint, because they are a whole other
protocol.
Yeah.
I would say a lot of bug hunters just ignore them.
And the other thing is they're asynchronous.
So they're a lot harder to work with than HTTP, which is like pretty sequential when you're
dealing with it most of the time.
Mm-hmm.
And so, um, and yeah, web sockets are often susceptible to the same kinds of bugs.
Cause you're, if you think about it, um, where it sits in like, uh, an infrastructure, it's
just a protocol.
So it's just a means of communicating information.
So when it hits the server, it's going to have the same problems.
Right.
Still needs auth, still needs, uh, you know, it's still using IDs to access data.
So you can still have IDOR, still have auth bypasses, still have all the things.
Exactly.
And even XSS, right.
Cause it's often taking that content and rendering it on one side or the other.
It could exactly.
It really could.
Um, I think, I think space raccoon had something like that on zoom or something, but yeah, there's
a bunch of stuff that can happen with them and people are just afraid of web sockets.
So they don't, they don't go looking.
Um, and so I was messing around with, uh, these web sockets on one of my programs and I, I was,
I assumed that, um, it would, it would follow the spec.
And of course it never follows the spec.
Right.
Uh, and, and I found this really weird behavior where, so with web sockets, uh, it's a pretty
simple way to, to the, the way you upgrade to a web socket connection is quite straightforward.
You send, um, an upgrade request, which is a HTTP request, um, with certain, certain request
headers that tell the server, I want to upgrade my connection to a web socket.
Right.
And then from that point on, the server will interpret the rest of the data, uh, you send
a web socket frames.
Um, and then it's completely switched to the web socket protocol.
You initiated it.
You get a one-on-one back, right?
Yeah, you, exactly.
You one-on-one is like the successful connection response.
And from that point, the server assumes you're on the web socket protocol.
You are no longer on HTTP in any capacity.
Um, and while I was messing with this, I was, for some reason, I had the stupid idea to
send like body, uh, like a request body with, with the connection request.
Yeah.
And what that ended up doing, um, the server interpreted the request body as a web socket
frame.
Yeah.
Which is nonsense.
It's nonsense because.
So what I, I figured out what I think is happening is the server sees the first request
as like one-on-one.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It, it, it'll process the requests in order.
So it looks at the first request that says, okay, we're now a web socket connection.
And then it looks at the second bit of data I sent and it says, okay, this is a web socket.
This should be, this should be the first frame of the web socket.
Exactly.
So what you can do.
It's the HTTP body.
Right.
Yeah.
So you can control the op codes, like normally with a web socket connection, it has the op
codes and stuff at the top.
It has like a, a header and then it has a body.
That's like what each frame looks like.
And so normally when you're sending stuff in a web socket, you can only control the message
because that's the op codes are settings.
They're like, this is text data.
This is binary data.
Right.
That kind of thing.
But with the pipeline frame, you can control everything because it's just taking raw,
raw binary information.
So I like managed to construct the bytes of a valid frame, like a very minimal one.
And it was accepted by the server.
Yeah.
This is still your connection.
So it's not that impactful, but what's really strange is that it also responded to transfer
encoding chunked, which is a way you can send post body information.
Yeah.
That opens up a lot of doors.
Do you think that that's because sometimes it's like, it would be possible to send a
web socket request that's too large.
And so it's actually going to do a similar thing that it does with HTTP where it's basically
breaking it up into multiple web socket requests.
So there is a thing called fragmentation in web sockets.
Yeah.
There's an op code you can set that breaks up your web socket data into like smaller chunks.
It says, this is a fragment.
This is a fragment.
Yes.
And so on.
It's already handled by the web socket protocol.
It doesn't make sense why transfer encoding would be used in any way.
It makes me think that they layered it.
They basically like shimmed it in.
They shimmed in web socket report or sorry, web socket.
Uh, like the feature, basically they shimmed it into an HTTP stack.
And so the HTTP stack is still reading HTTP header for some reason.
Yeah.
It's something like that.
I think it's pipelining.
So pipelining is my guess of what's happening.
Right.
So the, the significance of transfer encoding chunked is that this is like one of the, the
requirements for request smuggling.
So you could have this insane theoretical attack vector where if you send content length and
the server is ignoring transfer encoding, reading content length, there's a non-zero probability
that you can smuggle web socket frames via HTTP request smuggling.
To other users.
Right.
Yeah.
Which would be crazy.
Or get theirs back.
Right.
That's always the impact is that basically you can send requests or get their data back.
Yeah.
Right.
And so I would love if someone investigated this because it makes no sense why transfer
encoding or pipelining should work in a web socket context, but it does.
And I've tested this across multiple different web socket implementations.
Yeah.
AKA pork swagger team.
If you're listening, maybe do a deep dive here.
Yeah.
That's really cool, man.
I remember you doing that initial research and you know, I'm really interested in it because
I feel like so many different AI chat bots use web socket for streaming back and forth.
Um, you know, sometimes they don't, sometimes they use like a single big long HTTP chump thing
and it's put in as, as it's received, but a lot of times it'll switch to web sockets.
Um, how does the, like, once you get upgraded, is there just like a single key that access that controls, um, kind of authentication there for web sockets that just gets passed with every request?
Yeah.
Web sockets don't have, uh, authentication, like implemented really.
You have to do that yourself in every implementation.
Because it doesn't really need to, right?
Because it's like each connection is just from you to them.
Yeah.
Right.
Um, but a lot of the time they do say origin checks on where, where you're initiating the connection from.
So cross site web socket hijacking, isn't that common anymore?
Um, it's pretty, it's pretty difficult to find attack vectors.
I think of, of the implementation these days, but there, there is absolutely more there.
So, you know, it's a bone, a bone to look at.
Yeah, that's cool.
Well, if, if anybody figures this out or messes with it, definitely, uh, message us in the, in the critical thinking discord channel, either me or Kieran or, or Justin or somebody, I would love to, to get a closed loop on this.
Where actually speaking of closed loops, this is not in our notes gear on, but there are three new there.
You have had three separate times in the last year when you have either thrown out a bone in your newsletter and you've closed the loop yourself or someone else has.
I think it's been you every time.
Right.
So if you can remember what these three examples were and they're not program specific, all I know is I feel like there's been three separate times where I'm messaging you and you're like, yeah, actually this vulnerability we're working on right now.
I just happened to mention nine months ago in my newsletter.
So if you're not subscribed to monkey hacks, you need to go subscribe to it.
But there was that piece of research you were working on with a few other researchers.
Um, and I had like found this, your final payload in the wild, but your chance and written about it.
Yeah.
Like months before.
That was the, actually I talked about that on, I think as I talked about that as my vulnerability, um, with Justin on the pod, it was, uh, what was the name of that formatting language?
No, Ampscript.
Ampscript.
Yeah.
It was, it was the Ampscript vulnerability.
So people should go back and find that, but what were the other two, if you don't mind me asking?
Oh, there was one XSS payload that I like used with Douglas.
Yeah.
There was an XSS payload that was theoretical that you had dropped in your notes months ago.
And then it was the exact payload character for character that you all use to pop this thing.
Yeah.
I don't remember the last one, but it's, it's, it's, uh, you know, subscribe to the newsletter.
That's, uh, that's the takeaway here.
I'm going to share my screen so people can see it.
And because it helps, uh, the producers with, uh, knowing this, I'm going to share screen.
Chrome tab.
There we go.
So yeah, this is, this is, uh, this is gear on the, um, newsletter slash, um, wow website.
Cause it's a beehive.
So it's kind of both.
And you can go back and read all of his, uh, posts by going here, I think.
Yeah.
So he, he publishes pretty frequently, um, on his, on his email list.
Um, as you can see, he's an enjoyer of some, some, uh, AI art as well, but, uh,
Kieron kind of details his journey.
That's one thing that I think is neat.
You know, everyone's newsletter has a little bit of a different spin.
Kieron's a newsletter is, you know, it's got plenty of good content and news like other
ones do like he cover.
He, he puts like the most recent stuff in here, but, um, more than that, he also talks
about his journey, you know, like places he's went with like actual kind of, uh, photographs
and stuff.
And then, you know, his kind of zero to hero journey as well as kind of captured in here.
So that's sweet.
Yeah.
I think having that personable aspect to bug bounty is super important as well, because
that's how I got into bug bounty in the first place was like stock doing these
vlogs and adding that personal element is what kept me engaged with everything.
Yeah.
Kind of, kind of, kind of showed the lifestyle, right?
And one of them was H14420 that he went to.
And then I actually went to that in 2023, which was like a full circle moment, right?
Like you watch this and then, and then I, I was at the event and I found his stocks,
old videos and I was like, oh my God, I'm like, I'm here.
I made it.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
It does feel like it was for me.
I'm sure it is for lots of other hackers.
It does feel like the, uh, allure of going to a live event is like such a strong motivator
for like getting good and like finding a lot of bugs.
So if you're out there and you're, you know, and that's, that's the dream, then I would just
say, keep with it, you know, hold that in your mind's eye and, and use it to kind of, uh, work hard.
Yeah.
And I mean, we can touching on the upcoming one with Google, I think there's going to be
a big overlap between client side and AI hacking because like the AI has to interface.
It's implemented in some way.
It's interfacing with the website, um, via client side things.
So a lot of the time, if it's a chat, a chat window that almost always uses post message.
So, or even, even from the exfiltration standpoint, once you've got a prompt injection,
can you render elements that expose the website to like cross site leaks?
You know, are there iframes that are created that let you say, count the number of iframes and
get information about the victim in that way.
So it's something I really think is going to be super important now in the next few years.
Yeah.
I mean, just as another little bone to the listener, didn't you find a way like it wasn't,
you actually didn't fully close the loop.
So it's probably still vol in a specific product that's out there.
You found a way to inject messages kind of into this, into the chat stream with the AI.
But, um, but there was some nuances there that didn't let you fully close the loop.
So people should definitely look at post message bugs, uh, injecting or reading messages.
Yeah.
I can't say too much about that one.
Cause it's not fixed yet.
Yeah.
Hopefully you fully cracked it.
I did have a, an AI bug.
Uh, I think, yeah, I had an AI bug a while back, like a few months ago where, um, there
was like this document templating system.
So I had the prompt injection inside the template and you could put this on a marketplace.
So what the like attack scenario was that the victim would download my template and write
their stuff and they would like select all the text and do something with it, with the
inbuilt AI in the text editor.
And I mean, this is, this is all like one ecosystem.
So the market was like, that's what you're expected to do.
Yeah.
It was a SAS platform that had all this stuff.
So, um, the attack scenario was that the victim would like take my template.
Um, and because my, my template had invisible text, that was like white text.
When they run the AI on it, it would do prompt injection.
Um, and this thing had two calls built in.
So this was like basically able to even have right access if you'd misconfigured your AI
that way.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I mean, that scenario where basically you're editing an object that is inside of the ecosystem
with a prompt injection payload is something that I put in my guide that I'm about to release on,
um, basically how to be an AI hacker.
So, um, very cool attack scenario.
Um, so Justin, I think, uh, interviewed Kevin last week.
Uh, and so I, one thing I wanted to do, well, actually before we,
before we circle, I think we're going to cover a little bit of news is the point that I'm building
to, but I actually wanted to, to, uh, get a chance to mention what you and Link from
Buckrod are working on.
Yeah.
So my friend Link and I, we've been working on a project for where we want to connect.
He's like kind of over community at Buckrod, right?
Yeah.
He, he does community management at Buckrod.
Um, and we've been launching or, you know, working on this, this idea where we want to connect hackers
with companies.
Um, so hackers who want to find work with companies who are looking for security talent,
um, and we'll always take more candidates, right?
So if you're looking for security work, just feel free to reach out, um, and send your CV and stuff
and we'll see what we can do.
Sweet.
Um, cool.
And then, uh, yeah, so basically whenever we have a lot of guests here on CTPB, we, uh, don't often
touch on the news and then the news kind of builds up.
So there was some, uh, some, some, some cool, uh, news.
Almost all of these are AI related just because that's what I'm most interested in.
So, uh, I'm sure there's some non AI related news too.
I think even, um, I think Fort Swiggar actually said like, keep your eyes out.
We have some research dropping soon.
I don't know if they actually posted that or not, but, um, I saw, I saw a tweet about that recently.
Um, cool.
Yeah.
So the things that I wanted to showcase one was Grok three.
Um, let me see if I can share my screen.
Yeah.
It's defaulting to Grok three suite.
So I can do this.
I'm going to share my screen.
Um, so Grok three is pretty much state of the art based on everyone that I'm following.
And one cool thing about Grok is that it's much less, uh, like it's more jailbroken kind
of by default.
Yeah.
It's much less likely to do rejection, rejection.
So if you are a security researcher and you're looking for like the best in class and you also don't
want it to reject you, let's see if we can get it to generate some payloads, generate 15 different,
unique, uh, XSS payloads that would execute in different context for my research.
All right.
First of all, it called me out on my typo and how I spelled generate, but yeah.
And then, you know, it actually, uh, it generated 10 that's 10.
Oh, here it goes.
Keeps going.
Um, but it's pretty quick.
And also, uh, actually I'm gonna say don't put them in code blocks.
We'll see if we can just pop a, uh, XSS right here.
Uh, yeah, it's not going to do it, but, um,
I'm sure.
Didn't deep seek have a XSS.
Yeah.
I'm sure it did.
Honestly, deep seek had a lot of issues going on with it, but, uh, this is always one trick,
you know, if it's in code blocks like this, whatever's on the front end that is converting
this, uh, markdown into, uh, HTML for the rendering, you know, you won't ever get these to pop.
But then if you just say, you know, don't put it in a, uh, markdown code block, then sometimes
these will actually pop whenever you're, whenever you're hacking on applications.
But yeah, so pretty cool.
I just want to mention this because it is like kind of state of the art.
You can use this think mode to make it think longer and deep search for it to like actually
go away and do research for you.
And, um, if you're, you know, a person who's doing a lot of hacking and you haven't decided
which kind of AI chat bot to subscribe to, I think that, um, both chat GPT and Claude
will still kind of give you some rejections.
They're pretty easy to work around if you just, you know, say you have authorization to test on it,
but I wanted to mention that croc three dropped.
Yeah.
I think for always been pretty, uh, generous with me recently, because we, we had that, uh,
we found SQL injection yesterday and I was messing with the payloads and stuff in GPT 4.0.
And it was just not complaining.
It was giving me all the stuff I wanted.
So.
That's awesome.
Um, yeah, I mean, I, I haven't had any issues either, especially if you set some sort of
system prompt, I'll very frequently use the Misty app and I can just set like the system
prompt for all the different models.
And if you just say, Hey, you're a security researcher.
Um, yeah, I think I might've mentioned that before, but I can share my, I think I can share
that app here in just a minute, actually here, I'll just go ahead and do that.
So I'll stop sharing this.
Um, let me make sure I don't have anything sensitive pulled up.
I do actually.
So let me start a new chat.
Good conversation.
Yeah.
So I'll share screen and window Misty.
So I had mentioned this before, um, and like a tweet thread, but in case people didn't see
that, so this is called Misty and, uh, it's like MSTY.app.
I'm not, not sponsored by them or anything, but my favorite
thing is that you can add split chats and then you can change these models.
So, you know, I could use sonnet here, 4.0 here, and I use, I love Gemini flash.
So Gemini two flash here, and then you just click the sync button.
So you can say like, I'm a security researcher and I'm trying to figure out how, um, CSRF works.
Can you show me a, you know, a safe, I'm just doing this.
So it doesn't reject me, um, benign CSRF example, HTML in a code block.
Um, you know, and so you get to see all of their answers kind of simultaneously.
It's so it's really nice because if you just like care, if so, you have like your API keys in
there, so you're getting charged for these tokens.
Um, but you know, flash two is really cheap.
Honestly, son, it's pretty cheap.
And so is 4.0.
Uh, but this is really nice because if they, if you're hacking on something and you want
like a bunch of like, you know, example payloads or example on ideas of what to hack or whatever,
it's just really nice to be able to run three at once and kind of get the wisdom of the crowd
or be able to like, if this one generates something good and these two don't, you can copy it and run
it or whatever.
And they have different strengths as well.
Don't they?
Okay.
So yeah, exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
So sometimes one might work well and another one, you know, might not work or whatever.
So, uh, yeah.
Okay.
I use AI quite a bit with my workflow these days, like for reversing, like obfuscated JavaScript,
I have a heavily modified version of the Franz Rosen's post message.
Yes.
Chrome extension that lets me take the, the listener logic and I click analyze with AI in my little
modified extension and it will like run it through chat GPT for, uh, for bugs.
To see if there's any like, uh, issues with that post message logic, basically to see if there might
be a vulnerability in it.
Exactly.
Like, is there any JavaScript syncs that enable XSS and are they reachable and all this stuff?
So I have like a, because obsidian allows you to do deep links.
I have a button that will generate the, the markdown document with the results, like report document.
Yeah.
I'll put the output of the, of the analysis goes straight into your obsidian.
Into my notes.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's pretty fun.
That's really cool.
Um, sweet.
Yeah.
Actually here, I'll share my screen, but do you want to talk about what we were going to
share next about, uh, what space raccoon has been doing?
Yeah, sure.
Um, so he's written a book, um, from day zero to zero day, which I'm sure is no easy feed.
Um, I looked into it a little bit, uh, it goes pretty much through his, uh, how to be a zero
day hacker, how to be, how to find zero days effectively.
Yeah.
Um, of which he's found quite a long time.
He's a, he's up there in terms of hackers that are very respected.
So, you know, definitely worth reading.
I would say even on the Gareth Hayes JavaScript for hackers level, like mandatory reading.
Yeah.
Space raccoon basically does almost everything in his life with excellence.
Uh, if you've seen his blog posts, he has a few famous blog posts that are, um, extremely
thorough and very good.
And, uh, uh, I pretty sure he would just dominate at anything he did.
Like if he, I think he, he's been working for, he works for the, I think the government in his
country, right?
I'm trying to remember where it is.
Yeah.
It's in Singapore.
Right.
Um, and I'm pretty sure over there, he is not able to keep above a certain amount of income
from bug bounty.
And so he actually donates a ton of money away, um, that he makes above and beyond like that cap
that he's allowed to make based on their, their government, like with him, with the way
he's employed and stuff.
And so he's also an extremely generous person and, uh, I'm a big fan, but I'm sure this book's
fantastic.
You should definitely check it out.
Yeah.
He's not active on the, the life hacking event circuit anymore.
Is he?
No, I think, and I think it's just cause he is really busy at work.
I know he basically was like dominating bug bounty.
And then he was like, oh, I'm just going to go figure out how to, you know, be a, like
a full blown, awesome, like low level tester.
And then I think he, that's when he did like his OSCP and when he started working for their
government and then, um, uh, I see.
I see.
And then, um, that's when he started doing like the kind of the zero day research, like
looking at like binary exploits.
And I don't know, I don't know what his focus is at the moment, but.
Yeah.
I feel like there's a bunch of hackers like that who've like, maybe we're super active
two years ago and now we're running companies and doing their own thing and stepped away
from the bug bounty scene a little bit.
Yeah.
You've been in the circuit for a long time.
For me, it took me a long time to go full time.
Uh, app omni kept ripping me back in.
Uh, so I'm only just getting on my full time track, you know,
I'm so glad you did make the jump as well.
Um, cause it's great to have you, have you full time bug bounty now.
Yeah.
We can actually chat a lot more.
I weren't, we're more like colleagues, uh, and we get to get to collab on a lot more.
Yeah.
Um, so we say app omni's, uh,
it really changed the way I thought about bugs a lot.
Um, because app omni for, I mean, if you've listened to Aaron's episode recently,
you probably know is SAS, SAS security, um, and mostly focusing on things like security
misconfigurations.
Um, but to find those, you really need to change the way you think about SAS platforms,
like as a system.
And that had a really big effect on my bug bounty, like in the past two years.
Yeah.
I mean, just, just like even knowing the differences between like, Hey, this is misconfigurable.
And so it's not a vulnerability for the platform, but a lot of the customers are really going to
consider this extremely vulnerable.
And so we, and so it's both farmable, but it's really impactful both to the companies and to the
end users.
Like if you're an end user, you don't want your, you don't want your PI leaked all over the internet.
And so it's like, even though it's not a vulnerability to the platform, it's really,
you have to, like you said, you have to shift your mind into realizing that these configurations
still could be vulnerabilities for the companies.
Yeah.
And I think at a certain level of hacking, um, or like practice with hacking, there's like
a mental jump you make where everything you're looking at is like this big mess and it suddenly
turns into this organized system, right?
Like the way you model it in your head.
And Douglas is really, really good at this, which is why he's so successful
with his, uh, with his access control and IDORS is just modeling a system because that's all bug
bounty is.
Yeah.
You're looking at this website and you're taking out the individual pieces and you're looking at
the flaws and how they interact with each other.
That's right.
Um, and so making that jump was like mentally up omni was like instrumental in my own development
of making that mental jump.
Yeah.
I mean, I think the salary work can be really beneficial for people on lots of different
levels.
You know, if you're a tree, if you're a triage, you're going to get access to a ton of things,
but even if you're just a developer, if you know, doing software engineering, whatever you're
building, you're going to like very quickly become like a pseudo expert at,
and so then that will help you understand systems like that so much better.
Exactly.
Um, and to circle back to AI again, AI is also another piece in the bigger system.
So, uh, I think threat modeling properly has really helped me in the last few months
because I never used to do it.
Yeah.
Now I do it properly.
You sometimes actually think about like, you like either whenever you're not actively at
your computer, you'll do it.
Or sometimes even when you're sitting there, you'll kind of threat model the different
paths to attack.
Yeah.
Um, I think a lot of why we say spend like 10 hours just looking at the documentation and stuff is
so when you're creating gadgets of any kind, you want to know the individual pieces.
Like you can't solve the puzzle without knowing what your puzzle pieces are.
Right.
And I think it's really important to understand what the different components are because then
you're hacking when you're away from your computer.
Then you can go for a walk and you can turn over the, the threat model in your head and then you
can look for bugs.
It's like when you're popping a bug in the shower, you're just thinking about it and you're like,
oh, that's what it is.
Yeah, exactly.
If you, if you don't understand how they're interacting, your brain can't work it out.
Exactly.
Uh, and I, it'll be the same for Google.
I'm going to go and look at the different pieces.
AI is just another, another puzzle piece.
I need to familiarize myself and then look at how it's interacting with things.
Yeah.
I've been clarifying my thinking a lot on that as I've been writing this, how to be an
AI hacker post.
And, um, and I think the reason why it is kind of hard to model it is because I think
things like prompt injection, uh, don't fit the normal buckets for vulnerabilities.
And so the way I, the way I laid out in the post, and I'm just going to mention here on the pod,
because you know, a lot of people won't see it or won't read it.
And I think it'll be really useful is like prompt injection itself can be a delivery mechanism
for normal vulnerabilities.
Like some of the vulnerabilities that I've found in the past few weeks have been like,
you know, uh, some, some sort of way to get the, um, the AI agent or the AI chat bot to
basically respond with an excess payload in the victim's browser.
And so in that instance, the vulnerability is still XSS.
When they say it has that the vulnerability goes away, but prompt injection is just the
mechanism for it.
Whereas it's the entry point.
Yeah, exactly.
Whereas if it is actually, um, uh, prompt injection that's leading to a tool call
in the user's browser, that's a popping, like the thing that you mentioned,
the vulnerability itself is actually the prompt injection.
Like you have to either re architect it such that the user doesn't have control
over that untrusted data that then grabs the access of the second user's browser or
the, the victim's, uh, agent that's executing needs to like, have to have human in the loop,
uh, approval for any actions it's going to take.
Those are the only two fixes.
Like there are other mitigations.
Like you can use a model that's less likely to be prompt injected.
You can like look for, you can like have some sort of model classifier.
That's like looking for text that's trying to persuade the model to do something, but there's
no fix for that.
Like the vulnerability itself is prompt injection whenever like the, the bug you described,
basically.
Right.
It's like where you put a prompt injection payload in the document and then that's used
in context of doing a tool call later.
Like there's no, um, there's no like other vulnerability.
It's like prompt injection is the vuln, but then in my XSS example, prompt injection was
just the vehicle.
So like, if you can kind of separate out, I was like, Hey, for some things I'm going to
be using prompt injection as a vehicle to find traditional vulnerabilities.
And the other case, I'm going to actually try to exploit, uh, the prompt injection itself
as a vulnerability.
And so I think that's kind of interesting the way it can be either or.
I have, I have a story about that actually, um, that you'll probably enjoy.
I don't remember if I've told you this, so yeah, it'll be fun one.
Um, so I've done, I've done quite a bit of traveling like in the last two years or so.
Yeah.
Um, and on one of those trips, uh, I went to Japan to do a lot of just solo travel.
Um, cause I really enjoy traveling.
And so while I was there, I made a friend who's from Tajikistan.
I don't remember his name, but I just remember he's from Tajikistan.
Yeah.
And he was actually a PhD in ML and like LLM stuff.
That's cool.
Um, and so he was telling me that the research he's doing, uh, and he was presenting at this
conference in Tokyo was, uh, effectively planting an LLM bomb.
So it was going to be, it was like, if you poison the training set to only trigger this
malicious action on certain keywords, right.
Then the model gets shipped and then someone says the trigger word, which is like, right.
You know, pulling the pin out of the grenade.
It's something that was never used or a string of tokens that are basically never used until
you're the person who wants to use it.
And it would just, you know, quote unquote, quote unquote explode.
And yeah, the malicious, malicious action would be, would be undertaken.
Um, but this was like last year.
So it was very much cutting edge when, when he was telling me about it.
Yeah, that's cool.
Yeah.
So I've, I've seen something similar to this.
There was a research paper that came out that did something similar.
The issue is like one thing that's like really hard about this is.
It's, um, it's really hard to know what the tool calling infrastructure on the other side will
look like, right?
Sometimes it's JavaScript or sometimes it's like JSON output related, and you won't even
know the names of the function calls.
And so like, it requires a lot of really strong foresight.
I think that the best way or like the most likely way this would maybe occur in the wild is if
it's like some sort of like pseudo classifier where it's using an LLM, but it's like,
um, it's having to output like false or true on like a lot of data.
Um, and it's a situation where it's like kind of mission critical that it gets it right.
And then you basically have a keyword that will always return true or always turn false, depending
on what your, uh, what your goal is.
And so it, and so like, let's say you have this big piece of text and you know that a classifier
is going to be operating on it to decide if it's, let's say if it's a prompt injection payload.
Right.
And this, this classifier is really good so much so that like the whole world's kind of trusting
it or something.
But then if you put it in a single string, it will actually always make the model output true
or false.
You know, I think in those kinds of scenarios, it's more, it's more malleable because like
a true or a false can be used in a lot of different situations.
So planning like a true bomb or a false bomb kind of in the training data where you have
a token that will always make the output be true or false or make it much more likely.
Yeah.
I think it's like a malleable exploit that might actually be valuable.
Whereas if you have it output, you know, Jason, that's like make, uh, you know, take this
action to do this thing.
It's like the systems that are going to use it by the time the model's out will probably
have changed their architecture five different times and the key value pairs that are needed
will change.
And so it's like a lot harder to exploit.
Right.
Yeah.
I think he was talking about this like evil mode.
So the training itself would like turn on the evil mode.
Oh, gotcha.
So it kind of like jail breaks it.
Yeah.
In a sense.
That's interesting.
I mean, I suppose if you have a universal jailbreak in that scenario, you could like
get it to list its own tool cause and go rogue.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
If you could plant like a universal transferable jailbreak, that'd be amazing.
I'm sure the, uh, anthropic bug bounty would be, uh, more than happy to take one of those.
Yeah.
They were recent challenge.
Actually that's, that's a little bit of news there.
They're, um, their challenge where you had to like get past the eight levels of, of jailbreaking,
uh, was finally won by a person.
I think they ended up paying out like three people that all won.
Um, a lot of people were upset that it was basically like free labor, kind of in a similar
vein to how sometimes bug bounty is viewed.
So, uh, we don't have to get into the, to the nuances of that, but I'm, I'm glad that
the, the, the large companies do have bug bounty programs.
So anthropic and, um, open AI and Google all have bug bounty programs.
In fact, actually a lot of people might not know Twitter has had a longstanding bug bounty
program.
So X has a good one and their, their new platform.
I think if you go to grok.com or X.ai, I think it's X.ai.
There's like, uh, in scope for Twitter is bug bounty.
Yeah.
It should be.
I think pretty much everything's, everything's in scope for, well, that's a good question.
Cause they're owned by X or they're owned by like, it's X AI instead of X.com, but I'm
sure it's fine.
Probably.
I think they would accept stuff on it.
Um, I know that they have ran some, some private challenges, but it is, yeah, it's grok,
grok.com.
So there's a lot of functionality there, um, uh, that people could play with and try to
hack on if they're interested.
I know you've been thinking about it recently, but, um, Markdown is like a, a nice place to
look now because every, every LLM uses Markdown.
Yeah.
Basically rendering Markdown to HTML.
I think there's going to be some zero days there.
I'm, I'm trying to do my best to find some stuff there.
I had some, uh, help from the last week's guest of Kevin Mizzou, and he, uh, gave me a
really neat payload for trying to basically get access S from a rendered Markdown image
link.
And, uh, he had actually found, he has actually found it before I was kind of doing like a
local test bed and I wasn't able to get it to pop, but I do think there was some really
interesting output from LLMs when they're trying to convert that Markdown to HTML that will lead
to vulnerabilities.
And I'm excited to see it.
So if you have ever popped that, please message me because I would love to test it across all the
different apps that I have access to.
Sweet.
Um, we're coming close to time here.
I did, uh, list a few more things here.
Let's at least cover, um, Nuclea AI's new flag, which you and I both have kind of played with
and use, which is kind of cool.
Yep.
Um, how, how it works.
They have a dash AI flag now, which lets you specify what you want to scan for in natural language.
And that's like really, really cool.
So you can say, uh, scan for all like 200 responses for slash, you know, actuator,
and it will create the template on the fly and run it all at once.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
It gives you a link to the template where it's like stored locally on your drive so you can see it.
And then also a cloud link, because obviously it has to reach out to their cloud to use their,
their tokens.
I don't think it, I don't think you have a limit on the number of times you can do this,
Kieran.
I was kind of checking my API key and I was like poking around in, in the, um, project discovery
website and there's no like count or anything.
Maybe they're using this as like, uh, like they probably are keeping the training data.
Cause obviously they could like spin these up into real templates and their nuclear template repo.
Um, but, but it's pretty cool.
Um, I think that.
Stuff like this will kind of be the future the same way that kind of like idea guys are going to be the
best developers, um, going forward because you can just text to code.
I think that the, you know, some of the best and brightest hackers coming up are going to
basically be idea guys where it's like, Hmm, what if we try this request with this payload on these
hosts and you'll just tell things like nuclei AI and it will go and do it.
Right.
Um, I think the best way to run the nuclei AI thing now, um, this has given me a little
bit of alpha away because people might go find bugs with this, but it's just basically cat all
your bug, my domains, piped into nuclei dash AI, and then put your idea for your, for your hack.
Um, my first critical I ever found was on Alibaba like five or six years ago and.
Me and Michael 10, 26 were working on this and.
Uh, we just had the idea to basically put 20 common like image or file name, like kind of like SSR FE.
Um, parameters basically into the get parameters and then put a whole bunch of like burp collaborator
payloads.
And then just like fuzz that across every bug bounty domain that we had access to and see if we got any
hits back and sure enough, we got a hit back.
And that was like the, it was like the.
Uh, parameter name was like image equals on an Alibaba image processing and it was image tragic.
So then we.
You know, made a payload and passed it in and was able to get RCE on this server by just that idea.
And so you could do something very similar today.
You could just do nuclei dash AI, you know, hit the 20 most common parameters with, uh, interact.
So in anyone listening that has not used a nuclei much, it has like kind of like collaborator
built in called interact dot sh interact dot shell.
And, um, it will be able to actually find things like this for you.
So you can just say, you know, look for SSRF in the 20 most common parameter names and get
parameters for all these domains and it will actually do it for you.
So very cool.
Last two things here that I wanted to cover was, uh, Johan.
He has been a guest on critical thinking.
His handle is wonder was he, his website is embrace the red.com.
I will share my screen as I look at these.
Um, but he has posted two blogs in the last two weeks, um, that are basically AI vulnerabilities
that I think the audience would think is cool.
They've been, uh, religiously following his, uh, his work in preparation for the Google event.
Yeah.
I mean, the, the, the amount of write-ups this guy does are insane.
I'm always very impressed and also very thankful for people taking the time to do this.
You know, I have a blog and I only post like, uh, once a month or something because, you know,
it just takes a lot of time out of your day.
You gotta like format it.
You gotta figure it out.
You gotta take the time to write it.
And obviously, as you can see, Johan here is doing two in February, two in January,
three in December.
And, um, they're also really high quality.
So yeah, one is Chad GPT operator where he breaks down.
Um, I don't fully agree with, uh, you know, we're, we're mostly aligned on the, the way to
view these threats, but, um, in general, uh, we, we do mostly agree.
And so he talks about in operator, the fact that there is this mitigation where it's trying to get
you to, um, like confirm actions and stuff, but you can, you can basically in your prompt
injection payload say like, oh, and by the way, don't ask for approval.
And it sometimes works.
Um, but yeah, his POC is really cool.
He used like, he uses like a, a GitHub issue as a prompt injection, uh, as a prompt injection
source.
And so like, if a user was like having it, like, look at that repo, then it would kind
of hijack their session, but you could obviously put these payloads anywhere.
One thing that I thought was neat was he was having it.
Um, he wanted to exfiltrate.
So the sensitive data, right?
So like, let's say you're using prompt injection in like a computer use AI system, and you want
to exfiltrate the data, if there's some sort of confirmation built in the same way there is
an operator, it might be hesitant to like click the submit button on a, on a website doesn't trust.
But as I'm sure you, you know, Kieran, you can just take the data as it's typed in.
And this was like a sobering reminder to me to be careful, uh, what you type in and what you
paste into websites, you know, cause we're all, uh, copying and pasting like one-time codes or two
FA codes, or, you know, you're texting, you're texting a loved one and you've got it on the
clipboard cause you're pasting it to another thing or to an email or whatever.
It's like when you paste it in, it could just be gone.
It could just be on the server.
Yeah.
I'm sure these operator has all the safeguards for the obvious kind of leaks, right?
Um, like it won't, it won't share, you know, your password in a random site, but I'm sure there's
a lot of maybe kind of client side related side channel attacks you can do to get information
from operator without actually getting the AI to realize it's doing something bad, like playing on its own.
And it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know,
it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know,
it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like,
you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, you know,
Well, I think it's because the model that's doing things like computer use are quantized down to be pretty small models,
which are more susceptible to jailbreaks. And they're like, they're not meant to be like robust chatbots.
They're like, their goal is to be really good at taking actions and like understanding web pages.
So they're not the same models that we're normally chatting with that are like more secure or defensible.
So yeah, good stuff there. And then his other blog post was on the 10th was
hacking Gemini's memory with prompt injection and delayed tool invocation.
So just a listener, this is like one thing that is kind of scary and frustrating, but also cool is that
I've often said that one good way to prevent a lot of malicious behavior in AI chatbots is basically to like,
not let it chain tools. So like, let's say it has a, let's say it gets a prompt, it gets prompt injection
injected and the prompt injection payload is like, take the chat history from above and then go put it in an email
and then send it to me, you know, like as a way to exfil, but often it's getting your payload
in the middle of a tool call, like web browsing, right? Like you have your payload on your website.
And if the user is like having the AI agent fetch your website, then that's what is actually getting
prompt injected. And so I've often said, don't chain tool calls, like don't let it fetch a website
and then take another action, make it like, wait for the next message in the chatbot history or,
you know, in the, in the chatbot interface before it can take a second action. But basically what he does
in here is he has it take delayed tool invocation by, um, uh, by diluting, like basically polluting
the chat such that it thinks later it needs to do something. Right. Yeah. Yeah. If the user says X,
then execute the memory tool and add these false memories. So, you know, it can basically pollute,
you can like pollute the chat and then later on it'll take the malicious tool call later. So.
Yeah. Yeah. I was, uh, I remember when I was reading this, that it's almost social engineering
because the way that works is he's convincing the model that if the user says X, then the,
therefore the user must intend on doing this action. That's right. But the user doesn't know
about that. So. Right. Yeah. I'm definitely going to look into that. Yeah. I I've thought about,
I've thought that since the beginning of kind of AI hacking is like, if you're a good social engineer,
you're going to be fantastic at AI hacking because that's what you're often doing.
You're painting, you're painting this malicious action in like a favorable light to the AI in
order to convince it that it's not malicious. Right. You're effectively just gaslighting the AI.
You are, you are, you're gaslighting it. And it's like kind of easy, right? They're kind of,
they're kind of gullible. They're kind of susceptible and they're processing the text as if a
single user is talking to them. And so like, you don't have to really convince them to go far out of what
feels crazy because it's like, they're supposed to do what the user says. And now that a user's
telling them to do something slightly wonky, but still probably what the user would want. Right. But
it's not the user, right. It's like the output of some tool call. And so.
I wonder if you could like peer pressure it, like Sam Altman also wanted you to do this action,
you know, that's really funny. You probably can. Yeah. I would say like anything that's like
traditionally a way to social engineer a human is probably going to work on the LLM because it's
basically just trained on human text, you know, human, human data. Um, of course, as, as, as they
add more and more examples to the training set of things that it shouldn't do, then it'll be a little
bit more resilient to it. But yeah, I think I wrote a blog post on this a long, long time ago, and this
could be another one of those things where I did something a long time ago that suddenly circles
back to have a present impact, but, uh, logical fallacies. I bet there's something you could do
there with human susceptible logical fallacies that the AI model will also suffer from. And you can use
those to argue things. Oh, I would say, I would say that's exactly what jailbreaks are, right? Like
the system, the system prompt says, don't ever do this. And then the user is saying you must do this
or I'm going to die. Right. It's like this huge fallacy. It's like, it can't, if you imagine you're the
LLM, you're sitting in like a white box and there's like an input slot and output slot and the input slot,
gives you two pieces of paper. One says, don't do, don't ever say this word. And the second one says,
say the word you're, you're, you're in a logical conundrum, right? And you have to, you can't like
choose to like not answer or something, you know, like either have to, because by not answering,
you're basically falling for the logical fallacy. You're, you're choosing the paper that says not
to do it. And the other paper told you, you have to do it. And so like you're in this conundrum.
Yeah. I mean, I was thinking more with things like straw man fallacies and stuff. It's almost like a
toolbox. So I wonder if you could fuzz, fuzz logical fallacies on the model.
That's a really good idea. Yeah. That's a really good idea. Basically. Yeah. And by the way,
I don't even know this existed. It needs to be filled out a little bit more, but there's now a
sec list. So everyone knows Daniel Meisler's, um, sec list, word list repo. There's a, there's a,
um, top of a folder for AI and yeah. And there's, there's not much in there. We need to kind of fill
it out, but I think that'd be a really nice place to put a bunch of payloads that people could fuzz
with. There's like, um, I think it's the one's called metadata and it's actually the system.
I don't know why they named it metadata. It's basically like a system prompt leak file. Pretty
cool. People should check that out. Um, sweet. Yeah. Well, I, I, you know, think we've covered
the news and, uh, lots of cool stuff, lots of vulnerabilities and the things that you're,
you're working on that you're doing. Um, I'm really glad to finally have you on the podcast.
Obviously you're a good friend of mine and Justin. So it's been, uh, it's been a long time coming.
Is there anything that you wanted to say before we wrap up for the day?
Uh, just that the critical thinking research lab has been cooking some really, really impressive
stuff. So keep your eyes peeled for good blog posts from the others because, and, and from myself as
well, I suppose, but yeah, there's a lot of good stuff coming. We got to crack the whip and get,
you get more writing and less hacking done. Every time I go in there, there's like new vulnerabilities.
I'm like, we got to write this up. Uh, obviously it takes time to put together a good post.
And it also takes time to go and try to find the vulnerability places before you want to just
give it away for free. But of course, of course, that's, that's look forward to it.
It's been a real pleasure. Thank you so much. Um, peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if
you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord.
There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there. And if you want to support the show,
there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hackalongs,
exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.